and what's interesting about parent
excuses is if you reverse engineer them
backward to the seat of where it's
coming from
it means that a stunning majority of the
people in this audience are actually
tied up in caring about somebody else's
point of view on them and I'm really
fascinated by that fears holding you
back you know what you want to do the
only reason you're not doing is because
you're scared of doing what you actually
want to do so when you scared out
sailing still being at the same place
when my friends the next huge mistake
you don't want the same thing your
friends want so what do you care what
they have number one mistake so many
people make is they care about what
other people have but anybody has if I
have more if I less doesn't matter I
worry about myself the fact that you're
worrying about other people's
accomplishments is already a losing
formula you need to get rid of that
first then you can focus on yourself I
would argue that well more than 50% of
the people in this audience are here
today because they worry about the way
they would be judged by one end or two
family members in their inner seven
eight people circle if you're not
feeling it find new friends I'm being
dead serious about this this one is real
big for me who you hang out with is a
huge one again these are all trying true
things right we've heard the you're the
whatever of the five friends you spent
like that's real add one new winner
friend like you know what I mean had one
new winner friend and cut one loser
friend like yeah I know he's been your
boy since fourth grade but he sits at
home and smokes weed and plays 2k all
day like you can only love him so much
and to me that is the most fascinating
thing that's happening as I'm going
through my journey which is oh the
reason I am capable and and have the
luxury of standing up here is that my
parents parented me in a way that gave
me so much self esteem while respect
when I was nine years old and opened the
door for an elderly woman at a
McDonald's she reacted as if I won the
Nobel Peace Prize what my mom did was
super smart she overreacted on
everything that I was doing that was a
good human trait my mom built huge
self-esteem in me and I feel like the
biggest reason I am Who I am today to
everybody is cuz I feel so guilty and so
grateful for what she did for me
that I want to do it for everybody else
which is guess what you suck at a ton
good so does everybody else you're also
probably pretty rad at something try as
many things as possible until you figure
out what you're rad at and you like then
go do that for the rest of your life and
stop getting about everybody else
they're just an incredible you know like
kind of access point of like what you're
great at and what you love when you
stumble into being somebody like me you
really win when what you're naturally
great at is what you naturally love the
most and away you go and so I think what
you need to do is taste everything it's
kind of like food you know what your
favorite food is if you only eat one
food so I would take advantage of your
youth and and your flexibility at this
kind of age and try and taste everything
play with everything figure out what you
might be good at what you might like and
then you make a decision
it's a very fine balance I don't stand
up here not giving it about what people
think about me it's just that I care
just a little more about what I think
about myself that everybody else can
find
and I just think a lot of people are
crippled by going on the offense because
we are sold defense
we are sold offense we just our offense
is always the best defense offense
always solves problems as long as your
defense is not a complete disaster so I
just think offense is a very good
mentality there is a trigger mindset I'm
always trying to stay in office see I
always say say bye hear from everybody
wins you know I think the fear of losing
Trump's the excitement of victory for so
many people I think people are so scared
nobody wants the rejection nobody wants
to lose so I understand the philosophy I
understand that string of DNA that
doesn't want to make you lose but I'm so
desperate to figure out how to convince
people that there is no loss that yeah
you might get made fun of and you might
have it in your own mind but trying to
figure out how to make people who slop
that fear of going and building a
business for themselves in 2012 trying
to figure out how to make a video or
give a talk or send it to me or write a
book just something that makes people
understand that executing the way it
always is is gonna lead you to a place
where you're not going to win life's
funny bro and I think that a lot of
people are sitting here for another
reason than those two fear judgment of
others
this one's I'm obsessed with if you're
following me and I just think most of
you lack patience I tell these 23 year
olds 26 year olds all the time to be
patient because they should how old are
you
44 think I'm 40 do you know how young we
feel
it's when you were 26 did you ever think
that this is what 44 felt like no you
thought that that was finished yeah like
you think a 40 rose like when I was 25
years old I thought a 40 year old was
finished I don't even feel like I'm
starting it's a it's a balance of regret
and patience like you can go hard on for
three years do nothing right wake up and
be young you should really go to a
retirement home one day and volunteer
and just talk to them it wouldn't make
you wanna keep every minute of your life
because when you see regret in a man's
eyes it gains like because you have a
kid about it when you're 90 and you're
not mobile and tired and it's over you
can't do it you can't do it you can't
build that company want and you can't
spend that time with your kid you its
regret drives I think that patience has
been the disproportionate component of
my success so what should we do Gary
beep let's wrap this up what should we
do what should people do people should
stop complaining right peepers are good
they are good call people should not
listen to America propaganda of fixing
they suck at they should be tripling
down and what they're good at they
should be confident in certain areas but
you're not gonna become Beyonce or you
know like your bone structure is a
certain way like you're not gonna solve
everything your IQ can get a little bit
better but don't worry about the
incremental figure out what you put you
on fire and you're halfway decent at if
you're lucky enough right now to be
listening and you're good at what you
like become tunnel vision
because there's way too many voices
telling you what and how and here's the
other thing and this is the big one you
have the conversation with the person
that's holding you back the reason most
people who are listening right now we're
not doing that thing is they're worried
about the opinion of somebody usually
their mother usually their father and
the reality is is that your spouse may
be the person holding you back and
have to have that conversation cut them
off we have to get to a place where
you're doing you because the number one
thing that scares me is regret and
you're gonna sit there at 72 and you
gonna say I wish I wish I wish
and whether that's money or spend more
time with your family there's a million
ways to do this not everybody wants to
buy the Jets not everybody wants a
smoked weed on the beach and Bahamas
like everybody's got a different thing
figure out what the thing is and stop
making excuses who the president is your
mom did this like like I missed it I had
that idea for uber then why don't you do
it there's a reason that guys and gals
like me continue to have audiences
because people want to be motivated to
go and do things or they want to learn
tactics to go and do things but it's
whether I'm giving you tactical advice
like filters on snapchat or Facebook ads
or Instagram story collaborations or I'm
motivating you through my words because
I communicate that way or through my
actions
seeing this wake up at 5:00
if everybody who's watching this
actually did something about it and then
went on the course of their version of
it and then they wouldn't be watching
this and I genuinely know at the bottom
of my heart that of all the people that
want to build audiences that I'm the
complete opposite of almost all of them
because 99% of people that produce
content like this and are out there like
I am the business of being that is what
they are I have businesses
I have Wine Library Invader Nina I don't
need your 14 bucks for my book or to be
in my course or this and that so I don't
need to monetize you so I then genuinely
want you to never watch me again but the
problem is every time you guys are
posting do many times I see on like on
my Instagram oh I needed this today and
you know many times I see that person
nine months later still hanging around
if you needed it then take it and do
something about it
the reason there's gonna be a billion
motivational views today on YouTube is
that people love the feeling of being
motivated they don't like putting in the
work to do something about
I hate the motivation me
until you do something about it